[Musique]
c'est avec beaucoup d'attention et de
précision dans leurs gestes que ces
jeunes restaurateurs manipulent ces
objets d'art pendant trois semaines
ces étudiants à l'institut national du
patrimoine à paris vous restaurer cette
collection de pièces appartenant au
musée historique de villèle et là je
suis en train de reprendre les décors
sur la tribu les corps qui ont été
pensés auparavant pendant l'ancien
restauration et donc j'essaie de donner
une homogénéité lisibilité du décor ces
objets en céramique abîmée par le temps
reprennent de leur forme et de leur
couleur originelle entre les mains de
ses élèves
ce chantier école fait partie de leur
formation à la fois dans la restauration
et la conservation du patrimoine
il ya deux grandes façades dans notre
métier il ya le côté conservation
matériel qui est absolument essentiel
que sont le grand public méconnaît et
c'est notre rôle premier c'est de faire
en sorte que les objets sont dans l'état
dans lequel ils sont lorsqu'on
on l'y voit pour la première fois mais
on doit les stabiliser dans cet état là
pour qu'il ne s'abîme pas plus et ça
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle de la
conservation soit préventive soit
curative une fois nettoyée collet europe
1 ces objets retrouveront leur place
dans la collection permanente du musée
historique de villèle
[Musique]